today for our daily cancellation we're
all canceled everyone
everyone's canceled we're all canceled
enough is enough the
reason we're canceled is because a nasa
spacecraft just yesterday
landed on an asteroid 200 million miles
away
it landed touchdown collected samples to
bring back to earth
uh the the spacecraft left our planet
four years ago has traversed that great
distance actually has been
orbiting the asteroid for the last two
years and now we'll return home with uh
the mission completed
now understand that this rock about the
size of the empire state building
is traveling 60 000 miles an hour just
think about that nasa sent a spaceship
200 million miles away that's over four
times the average
or rather the minimum distance between
earth and mars they sent it
200 million miles to an object only the
size of a building
landed it in an area the size of three
parking spaces
touching down only three feet from the
precise targeted location
that is an utterly amazing engineering
feat it's mind-boggling it's spectacular
there's even a short video uh footage of
the event
why does all this mean that we're
canceled well because instead of talking
about that
about that tremendous and fascinating
subject
we've all been talking about jeffrey
tubin's penis
and borat and god knows what else this
is how it always goes we live in a
universe of wonders we're surrounded by
by by the astonishing the bewildering
the incredible
and none of that can hold our attention
or attract our interest
the way a story about a man publicly
masturbating can or the way that any
gossipy nonsense can or any pointless
controversy
we all complain about this though i hear
from people all the time oh i wish the
news would focus on positive
interesting things more people
complained to me about it about my show
matt i agree with you but i wish you
talk about positive things
no you don't no you don't you say you do
but you don't
we all say we do but none of us really
do the fact is
the positive the interesting the
non-controversial
these stories are out there that content
is out there
it just doesn't attract much attention
unless it's a story about like
a dog helping a blind man find his
favorite hat
and there's a cute two and a half minute
video we can share on facebook
that story you know is positive and the
video would get 15 billion views
but positive and significant positive
and consequential
positive and truly interesting those are
the stories that
almost nobody really cares about except
in theory
and if i were to spend a week talking
only about those kinds of positive
stories by the end of that week
i'd have maybe five listeners left my
audience would literally be cut in half
so we're all complicit we prefer the
inane the empty
over the wondrous and the enthralling
another example last year
there was a picture of a black hole
released first time ever that a black
hole has been photographed
you can see it here now that is an
object
55 million light years away 55 million
light years a light year 6 trillion
miles 55 million times 6 trillion you do
the math i certainly can
and this thing is 6 billion times the
mass of the the sun
the word gargantuan doesn't begin to
describe it a force of power
beyond anything we can imagine anything
we've seen across distances
too vast and too empty to be
comprehended this picture was released
and you know what most people said it's
blurry
it's blurry it's boring i'm bored let's
see what kanye west is tweeting about
but i suppose that's better that
reaction is preferable to when five or
six years ago
a module was landed on a comet 300
million miles away
and the discussion around that event if
you remember remember centered around
the allegedly sexist shirt
of the scientist who headed up the
project
at least nobody found a reason to be
offended by the asteroid landing
yesterday or the black hole
but i'm sure our best minds are figuring
out a way to make that happen
i i really believe i really do that
aliens could land on this earth emerge
from their spaceships and start
revealing the secrets of the universe
and it wouldn't even trend on twitter or
make headlines on cnn
unless the aliens said something
homophobic or racist
or if they mention that they support
donald trump then in that case sure
global news cnn's headline would say
something like
aliens invade earth stir controversy
with offensive comments
then there'd be the buzzfeed article
replete with gifts and snarky one-liners
with a title like 10 most problematic
things the aliens said when they came to
earth
the aliens would look around shake their
heads and say holy [ __ ] you people are
stupid
and then leave they were going to tell
us how to cure all known diseases
harness energy directly from the core of
the sun but never mind
and after they leave within 12 hours the
new cycle will have moved on
three months later someone will somebody
will post a massively viral tweet
that says lol remember the time aliens
came
and there'd be like a gif from
spaceballs or mars attacks
and that would be the only record of the
event humanity's
last word on the subject so we're all
canceled
we're cancelled for being us for being
human it's our greatest flaw
and on that appropriately dour note and
depressing them
i will end the show for today the last
show from my home here which is also
cancelled
this studio in fact my first studio that
which would of course be my car
was hauled away to the junkyard just
this morning and now this
so this is a time of change
of endings and new beginnings
so that's gonna do it for me have a
great day
farewell godspeed hey you uh
yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated